truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing
i'm glad he's on our side
yes that is our first look at chris pine
reggae jean paige and michelle rodriguez
in their new dungeons and dragons movie
it is going to be
so good and we are exclusively with the
cast here at comic-con in san diego
all right it's been described as
guardians of the galaxy-esque can any of
you elaborate on that i think it's game
of thrones okay with princess bride
with a little bit of spinal tap
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it
so how do we pull that off
uh
figure it out over a drink probably best
i love that i think that dragon is
definitely
dungeons and dragons honor among thieves
also stars hugh grant and it's sophia
lillis the movie hits theaters march 3rd
2023 and yeah it's based on the classic
board game i played with my family and
had the best time i had in years
there are famous faces that love this
vin diesel
yes he's
he's a total dungeon
when i first met vin
i'm over at his house and i'm and i'm
like dude
what is up with your closet full of dnd
dungeon master paraphernalia like he's
like yeah i'm a dungeon master maybe
that's my future
i like the idea of being a dungeon
master that sounds very british
we also need courage
magic
and you have you experienced playing the
game at all i have a little bit um in
high school um we had a little d d club
it was just basically
everyone that i knew my friends from
school just
did a short campaign together and sadly
we actually never finished it because
everyone
got busy and had to do their own things
but we've been wanting to get together
again comic-con is back in person for
the first time since the start of the
pandemic but chris isn't the only
captain kirk in town og william shatner
is there too along with paul wesley who
stars as the current tv version of kirk
are the three you gonna meet up i mean i
would love to i just got i got some
bigger fish to fry with the d and d
pals
oh but that'd be a great that'd be a
great insta shot we're all internally
doing the spiderman picture
all right michelle i want to touch on
something real quick fast 10. you got a
bunch of new people coming in you got
rita bree and jason what's it like
welcoming the new faces to this iconic
franchise we all love so much dude i
don't know i just count my blessings bro
like who'd ever thought after 10 you
know 10 movies in like come on bro like
what is up
like you literally like i'm i just it
never ceases to amaze me i'm just in it
and then i'm just like whoa we actually
did that okay
i really didn't believe we'd pull that
off but okay i love it
[Music]
you